hello I'm Xena but are we welcome to
this intelligence squared debate coming
to you from Cadogan Hall in central
London we have a very contentious issue
for you today our motion is send them
back the partner marbles to be returned
to Athens now as I'm sure most of you
know the partner marbles are those
classical Greek sculptures that once
adorned the Parthenon temple in Athens
sometimes known as the Elgin marbles
well for 200 years they have enjoyed
pride a place at the British Museum in
London
is it time to send them back or should
they stay where they are where we have
four speakers are going to be debating
our motion for the motion British MP
Andrew George and also broadcasters
Stephen Fry and arguing against the
motion British MP and historian Tristram
hunt and professor of history Philippe
Fernandes our mesto that is our panel
welcome to you all
tell me what's going to be happening our
speakers aren't all going to be making
their case to you and then I'm going to
throw the debate open to the floor and
our audience were actually polled as
they were coming in to see where they
stand on this motion and at the end of
our debate we're going to ask our
audience to vote again to see if any
opinions have shifted so first of all
our first speaker the Liberal Democrat
MP Andrew George who is also chairman of
Marbles reunited which is a British
campaign dedicated to sending they part
in the marbles back to Athens your time
starts now thank you very much zeyneb in
our view and that is Stephen and I for
for Britain to enable the reunification
of the path the marbles would not be a
humiliating climb down for Britain it
would not open the floodgates leading to
the emptying of the British Museum it
wouldn't undermine our ability to be
able to compare and contrast cultures
and human endeavors across the world and
across across time but it would be the
right thing to do it would it would
right or wrong the manner in which the
marbles were frankly pillaged from an
occupied country at the time using a
dodgy dosia the concept of offer of a
universal museum is something which has
only been kind of constructed during the
the period leading up to the creation of
the of the New Acropolis Museum a
magnificent Museum and we do have a
choice on the one hand we can persist in
in clinging on to the Greek Marples as
exclusives were thin until we're forced
in some kind of cringe making and rather
shameful climb down to hand them over in
some perhaps decades to come or as
Stephen and I are seeking to argue
believe that Britain actually wants to
appeal to Britain's own better instincts
than than the rather arrogant
acquisitiveness which has been displayed
at times in the past we should be
leading an initiative to reunify the
marbles a British triumph doing the
right thing a graceful act we are seen
to offer and cooperate Britain standing
proud enhancing
our reputation in return receiving as we
never be would a rotation from the
Greeks over time in the decades to come
of some of their finest sculptures and
artifacts which would more than
compensate for the loss of the path and
freezes and meta pays rather than
rehearse I think the many arguments that
have been pursued in the past about
whether they were acquired legally and I
think the Furman that was secured from
from the the Ottoman Empire at the time
by Lord Elgin only allowed him in any
case to to sketch to to take castings
and to and to gather fragments that were
scattered in on the site itself not to
amputate and to butcher and to demolish
the the the structure of the path on
itself in order to be able to drag these
freezes and meta pays from from from the
from the Parthenon itself if you support
the the logic and rightness of the of
the of the unifying of the of the path
no marbles and the logic really is that
they should be seen in the context of
where they come from and the building to
which they were originally attached this
is not a case to advance Greek
nationalism or apply in appropriate
modern political significance to to
remarkable artifacts it is a call from
Britain British people for Britain to do
to do the right thing to do something
graceful and triumphal to say we
celebrate diversity in this country and
rightly so and we should respect the
diversity of the world outside our
borders Thank You Xena
Tristram hunt against the motion that
the partner Marva should go back British
Labour MP and also historian so your
time starts
let me say first of all where our
argument this evening does not reside
there is no cultural chauvinism here we
all know that even in the current
straitened times that athens is just as
well-equipped to look after the marbles
as britain the curatorial interpretive
conservation skills at the acropolis
museum are equally as world-class as
those at the british museum
secondly when it comes to the history we
are not going to suggest that Britain
should keep the marbles because if Lord
Elgin had not taken them then the French
would have done so what is true and is
important to acknowledge is that for all
this talk of dodgy dossiers the marbles
came into the possession of the British
Museum legally and this is what makes
the case so different to any parallels
with the Nazi looting of the 30s and 40s
or the antiquarian thefts of recent
decades the Parthenon sculptures were
acquired in the early 1800s according to
the existing laws of the land this might
be uncomfortable to acknowledge but it
is important to establish the facts at
the time of Lord elegans excavations the
Ottoman Empire had sovereign authority
over the Parthenon and specifically
transferred the ownership of the
property to elgin's
and the legality of the Elgin expedition
has been in effect acknowledged by the
Greek government which has never
challenged the ownership of the marbles
in an international court of law so
legally the case lies with the British
Museum the question is one of morality
and functions our argument this evening
is that the marbles are a vital conduit
for the cosmopolitan interchange of
ideas and culture and must remain so I
have the great privilege of representing
the great city of stoke-on-trent in
Parliament and when I go around the
world and I see Wedgwood China in Bombay
museums and mint and tiles on the floor
of the Capitol building or Royal Doulton
designs in Melbourne I don't think we
have to get this stuff back to North
Staffordshire as quickly as possible I
think how wonderful it is that the rest
of the world is coming to know of the
great history of design and
manufacturing in the Potteries but if we
send back such an iconic collection as
the Parthenon Marbles we have indeed
started down the slippery slope which
would rob our museums of their capacity
to nurture a cosmopolitan sensibility
the purge might begin in the Devine
gallery of the British Museum but before
long we are emptying the Egyptian
galleries of the Rosetta Stone as well
as the Ethiopian tablets the oxen
treasure and the Benin bronzes the move
would be emptied of its Venus demillo
Apollo Belvedere and Borghese gladiator
The Hermitage would lose its Madonna
litre the Pushkin its Priam's gold and
so the list goes on who knows perhaps
even the National Gallery in Athens
would have to rescind its Bruegel's its
dellacroix its Mondrian its Picasso for
the result of such tit-for-tat
Recovery's will be a global loss of
learning of appreciation of
understanding whereas at the moment the
Parthenon Marbles are a part of a museum
that celebrates the historical and
cultural context of their form it points
to their global significance in the
context of ancient Greek art culture and
comparative global civilizations and it
does so in a museum that speaks to the
real message of the Parthenon sculptures
and Athenian civilization this is a
museum not interested in petty
nationalism invented traditions and
imagined monuments instead in its
enlightenment origins when the classical
virtues were rediscovered it revives the
lessons of ancient Greece it is a global
vision of cultural exchange and humanism
and in our fraught age of mass migration
post colonialism economic depression and
the communal Reaper
of terrorism this approach offers a
cosmopolitan ideal beyond race ethnicity
and religion which is vitally important
to modern culture the people of Greece
should have intense pride that their
Parthenon Marbles sit in the midst of
the British Museum and that is more
important than ever today in the 1930s
economic depression led to xenophobia
nationalism and cultural retrenchment in
these equally stress times we have to
work together to ensure the same
mistakes are not repeated we need
internationalism not nationalism
cosmopolitanism not chauvinism the
sharing of cultures not the worshipping
of icons Athenian civilization and the
Greek heritage is an idea as much as a
place and now is the moment to be true
to that calling and to reject the siren
calls of restitution enlightenment
civilization cosmopolitanism all these
ideals yes Andrew lofty ideals
high-minded ideals demand the marbles
remain available to all free to all the
world in the British Museum ladies and
gentlemen I urge you to reject this
motion and remain true to the marbles
thank
mr. hunt thank you very much indeed and
arguing for the motion steven by writer
actor broadcaster you name it he's done
it all is getting arguing for the motion
I'm firm I was very disappointed it just
him hunted and Marvis MP in a splendid
man in a very fine historian he had she
used the phrase slippery slope and the
very fact we want to return the freezes
and the metaphase of what now everybody
is far too embarrassed only very
recently to call the Elgin marbles
the very fact we want to return them to
the place where they were born does not
mean that the Rosetta Stone is going to
go back to Egypt as has already been
said the idea that a museum is some
whole perfect finished Victorian idea of
a kind of pantechnicon of all world
knowledge is nonsensical like all things
it changes and my proposal to you is
very simple how classic it would be if
you went in to the British Museum and in
the place where now you see the phrases
that algún took you saw a film of how
they were cast because they can be cast
unlike a painting you can only
photograph so what you would see when
you went to the British Museum you would
see a period 200 years in which we
curated them beautifully and they will
send see the journey of these
extraordinary pieces of pentelic marble
being returned to within five miles of
mount pent Erica web where the marble
was quarried and where that
extraordinary temple the Parthenon was
erected to Paris Athena the goddess of
Athens the reason its importance in
Athens is because it's all about Athens
there are 192 soldiers on the freezes
because 192 soldiers died at the Battle
of Marathon and it was between the
Battle of Marathon than their own defeat
at the hands of the Spartans between
that period Periclean Athens that saw
the rise of everything that our culture
now depends on
philosophy logic Euclidean mathematics
empiricism a refusal to take on trust
anything that is told to you Socrates
died by that principle history algebra
astronomy justice the areopagitica the
hill up to which they went to dispense
their justice every citizen available to
do by no means was it a perfect society
women did not have equal rights
pederasty was rife but heck I was at a
public school there's nothing new there
so the fact is everything our
enlightenment is predicated upon Athens
and around that time the Enlightenment
it so happened the Ottoman Empire had
completely overtaken Greece now the idea
that it was a legitimate purchase by
John Bruce at the Earl of Elgin is like
saying the American ambassador to the
Netherlands went to Amsterdam when the
Nazis had invaded and did a deal with
the Nazi ruler of Holland to buy
Rembrandt's Night Watch and it was all
signed yes we are we are the Germans we
own Holland's we are they are under our
occupation and you can have it it's
yours
and then Congress then said yup yeah
it's perfectly legal we now own the
Nightwatch Greece was under occupation
nine years after nine years after Elgin
took those raped those beautiful and
extraordinary pieces of history Byron
died for that cause there are more
statues of Byron in in in Greece than
their own Britain and the Greeks started
their war of independence against the
Ottoman Empire which they eventually won
in the eighteen thirties 1832 I think
so we're not talking about some simple
business of an English ambassador doing
a deal with a legitimate government who
gave him the right to take away the
stones of the temple that absolutely
characterized and personified the
greatest civilization the world had yet
seen the one on which ours is predicated
and all I'm saying to you is wouldn't it
be classy if we as Britain said yes for
200 years it's true we've saved it if my
neighbor has a fire and and and I go
over I say well I'll take the paintings
a bit before they get burnt I'll put
them in my garage and they come back
three years later and so come my
paintings back oh no oh no you can't
have them back they'd be burnt if I
hadn't taken them that's that's no
argument
that's just beastly this it's just beast
leaders and perfidious Albion which is
the name by which Britain has been known
for so long it's dis untrustworthy
country that still has colonial
ambitions let's not be that anymore
let's be a classic country let's make an
exhibition in the British Museum of
which Britons could be fantastically
proud which shows our curation of these
extraordinary marbles and also shows
their transportation back to the
Magnificent new Acropolis Museum where
they can be reunited not in the same
temple because that can never happen but
bear within through the glass in the
blue light of Greece a country
struggling desperately under debt we can
show them that no matter how much their
sovereign debt crisis means they owe us
we will never ever ever be able to repay
the debt that we owe Greece think
now making his opening statement against
the motion is Felipe Fernandez our mesto
professor of history at not redeem at
university in the United States and your
time startsnow
I'm going to do what I usually do at
these debates and dessert the brandies
and come down and join you
can the cameras depart with our
professor on our side of the house we
have a great international treasure
indeed a global treasure a treasure for
the whole world which is the British
Museum which thank God
yeah has abandoned at some time vocation
as a national and imperial institution
the British Museum is a resource of the
world in fact it is the great archive of
the history of the world in terms of its
material culture the documents of the
material culture of the world are best
represented in the British Museum than
anywhere else
III it British Museum now only in the
sense it happens to be for historic
reasons in Britain and is supported by
British taxpayers for the benefit of the
whole world it's a museum in which every
great civilization is represented but
now is privileged every religion appears
but none is preached it's a genuinely
universal place and of course now I we
did say all this I have said it wouldn't
be proper for the Greeks to display
these these artifacts but it's a
different sort of it would make to them
if they were transferred to Athens
wouldn't be that they would be in a
different kind of music
a museum which is a mirror rather than a
window a museum the significance of
which is local regional national in
which people can look at the artifacts
from the Parthenon in the context of a
history of Athens and degrees whereas if
some of those marbles those which are
present for historic reasons in the
British Museum's connection stay here
you can appreciate them in the context
of the cultures with which they are
directly comparable in the rest of the
world you can see what Athenian
civilization be if you believe as the
gentlemen on the other side of the house
or so eloquently said if you believe
that there's something special some
special greatness in ancient Athens you
can only appreciate that if you look at
it comparatively in the context of other
great civilizations of the time that's
why we have to have places like the
British Museum in the world and why is
the greatness of ancient Greece along
with that of other civilizations has to
be represented there by great and
important artifact we don't play that
you know Britain is in some way a
continuation of ancient Britain modern
Greece is not a continuation of ancient
Greece I did have time to dismiss the
remaining points made on the other side
of the the house but I do have time to
appeals you to keep intact the British
Museum of precious resource which this
country has maintained at its own
expense for the rest of the world if you
violate the integrity of the collections
I that there is no tsipras safe ghostly
honorable gentleman is right about that
I don't believe in precedent time of
professional intellectual I spend my
life shattering precedents that
unfortunately the courts due respect
precedents and if we violate the
integrity of this collection it will be
decimated whizzing all British Greek or
Spanish if you're a citizen of the world
defend the British Museum vote for
it's integrity and survival tonight not
for Greece not for Britain but for the
world I beg you to join me in opposing
emotion
all right well thank you very much
indeed
panel for your opening statements
arguing you're putting your case now I'm
going to throw it to the audience you
can put questions or comments to any of
our panel members but before we do that
I want to let you know how you voted on
this motion send them back the part of
the marbles should be returned to I
think stroke briefs immediately okay
for that motion 196 196 against the
motion at 202 very close but the dope
noes are a hundred and fifty eight so
that's very exciting it means that this
side could win with this side we could
win or to play for gentlemen so let me
ask for comments and questions from the
floor I'd like to ask first of all if
there is anybody Greek in our audience
Wow
plenty look like she'll a little
children so many of you I had no idea
okay
Greek with a microphone microphone I
said any of our words are are they
Stephen right and I would like to just
give you some bullet points that the
marbles has been very well taken care of
by the Greeks in Athens the marbles have
survived two world wars two bankruptcies
one civil war and one dictatorship and
they were very very well taken care of
during these times so I think this
indicates about the priorities that the
Greeks have and you also mentioned and
that they were legally acquired in the
eighteen hundreds this is a very gray
area and I would expect you not to have
made such a firm a statement and I'd
like to remind you there is no Furman
there is only a translation in Italian
and there is no feminine assad's but the
letter that was not a fair manner such
okay thank you another Greek with a
microphone
okay yes are you agree well okay when
the spirits of a senior democracy
perhaps I can definitely I think on
Stephens point about comparing the
Ottoman Empire with Nazi Germany was a
cheap shot the Ottoman Empire was not an
answer Germany in fact many in fact
perhaps the majority with senior
officials were in fact Greek if the
cosmopolitan multinational Empire
created an obviously big there were
atrocities but it was not the Nancy
Empire any stretch of the imagination
and finally I did go to the museum last
year I beg to differ from with all due
respect I do not think it's a great
museum it reminded me of Stansted
Airport in its architecture it is
certainly not the British Museum and a
second very very important point if you
go to the Acropolis and go to the top of
the Acropolis there has been restoration
of many of them monuments on top of the
Acropolis and last 15-20 years and the
obsessive b2 mill vandalisms
so I really do question your point also
that the authorities in Greece able to
protect these marbles the restoration
that has been done on the Acropolis not
20 years is appalling all right we'll
get a response we're getting
it's even a valid point they're made
about the Ottoman Empire and Nazism is
just the best recent occupation example
I can think of but it was an occupied
country
yeah but the Ottomans governed their
lands with a light touch as you know and
they know years later the Greeks
rebelled and were allowed to have their
own country and we're a good not
comfortable that it's not comfortable in
the sense that all the terrors of Nazism
did not attend the Ottoman Empire it was
an occupation the point is the occupying
force does not have the right to sign
away the goods of the country that
they've occupied all right um Tristram
this point about the Fermin and i should
say that a Fermin is a license and
letter of instruction which Lord Elgin
received at the time from the Ottoman
Empire so that he could remove this but
there is some question or some people
doubt that it was actually I mean
something you said out because of the
Italian translation so on I mean do you
accept this a little bit of a gray oh
well I I actually don't because if it if
it is a gray area then then why hasn't
it been challenged in in a court of law
the whole point about the Nazi looting
for example this has been systematically
challenged and questions of ownership in
courts of law and you can go to any
number of international courts of law to
pursue this and it it never was I think
I just think that the Greeks didn't want
to diminish themselves by actually
taking early you know illegal your
remedy to this to this issue is quite
clear that the Greeks want to engage in
a negotiation which an enable along a
long term loan I mean what were the
problem with the problem with the
negotiation so far every time the issue
is raised you can't get beyond a
precondition that the British government
and and the British Museum are saying
that you have to renounce legal title
before we commence any negotiation with
you but and that is a clearly cherish
and ridiculous way in which you are
intimately right and if the question of
ownership is settled
ie the Greek government agrees to the
ownership of the marbles under the
auspices of the British Museum then the
British Museum has said time and again
that they're very happy that be
delighted to lend the artifacts but at
the root of this question is do you
believe in a national conception of
culture or do you believe in an
Enlightenment cosmopolitan International
inception of culture I just want to pick
up one thing that Tristan said in the
light of the Greek contribution about
the fact that the Greeks do not dispute
the ownership I mean they have
acknowledged publicly
Evangelos Venizelos who was Culture
Minister back in 2003 wrote to the
Sunday Times newspaper and said that the
Greek government's position is that they
do not accept that the trustees of the
British Museum owned the Parthenon but
that is the point and that's why we
can't have the mature relationship in
terms of loans and scholarship that we
all want to see we're not all getting
left Athens with his booty his pride art
they would turn that him he left some of
it behind in Italy and it belongs to
Italy as it were belonged to Italy and
in 2008 the Italian president took this
isn't those elements if we slope isn't
it no it's quite the answer he just the
Italian president said well these are
these belonged to the pastor and he gave
back there was a ceremony ceremony in
which he said there you are prince you
could have any okay what didn't happen
was Greece said ah now you've given us
that one you must give us all the others
there was no slippery slope lots of
hands there now okay audience who's got
the microphone near them
I wondered is there something to inform
both sides of this argument that there
is such passion about the return of
these particular works of art other
works of art that have been taken from
other countries never seem to be the
focus of this type of perpetual argument
and I guess we could say on both sides
that that would inform for and against
and I wondered if you could just briefly
touch on why you think these sculptures
inspire people to this degree
okay very briefly why are these unique
but just why they unique but they
haven't been in the past this is what's
interesting for 150 years you didn't
have this kind of emotion sir
pounding them so it says something
interesting about modern Greek identity
and nationalism but that doesn't
necessarily speak to their innate
aesthetic virtue okay who's got the
microphone I'm dismayed to hear so much
discussion about the legality of this
transaction I believe that society has
led us to think legally and to somehow
totally forget that there are morals and
ethics that with I think we should be
standing by and referring to a previous
speaker if some of the marbles we're in
Stansted Airport so much the better
they'd be seen by millions okay so this
gentleman here the main thrust of the
problem of the marbles has not been
discussed tonight they are a single work
of art they represent the Panathenaic
procession they should not be divided if
the head of David was in the British
Museum and his body in the Offit's II
gallery we should think it was strange
those marbles should be reunited okay
thank you
some people think that because the
marbles are universally agreed to be one
of the most important symbols of Western
culture that putting them in the same
place with them at risk if there were a
fire or an earthquake or a terrorist
attack at some symbol of the West and
that by keeping some in Britain some in
Munich someone to Louvre some Elkins
house I'm at the Parthenon Museum were
sort of safeguarding against future
accidents because we couldn't really
afford to lose them and I was wondering
if anybody has any opinions on that
thank you
well I think I think one of the ends of
an answer that by saying that the moment
the British Museum can basically concede
that it is not the owner then the Greeks
will take them and the Greeks will be
happy to loan them around the world
that's the point that the moment think
what I mean I mean there is a
conservation issue with taking them
around the world I mean there are there
are delicate the British Museum is
willing to make lens of the parcel and
marble subject the usual requirements
which attend all such exchanges
concerning security and insurance and
conservation costs but it is absolutely
critical to any lay the part of the
condition is that you should be willing
to give it back and unless you know
people are willing to give it back it's
not alone it's another pillage it's
another big thank you hundred years it's
good enough but the fence is making the
point that that's the British Museum's
position that there's a lady there yeah
and then I'll come back to the panel the
legal case does not rest in favor of the
British Museum unless you have read
nothing they are the receivers of stolen
goods and the British government at the
time was the handler of stolen goods the
refusal to return them now is based on
such patronizing empirical attitudes why
should the Greeks be proud that the half
their marbles are in the British Museum
why should they would we be pleased nay
honored if half a stone Stonehenge was
up Rome I think not I don't know about
that I'll be I'll be I'll be very
pleased to have as much of British
culture shown around the world as a
symbol of our history and heritage and
identity the Greeks should be
you're so proud why one of the top three
museums in the world which gets the
largest the third-largest volume of
attendees in the world has pride of
place for the symbol of Greek
civilization I know believe in
internationalism either you believe in
cosmopolitanism and you believe in the
values of a part ordinarily they aren't
exactly bathed in Aegean light are they
in the glue well of the gallery in which
they are shown and small and the British
Museum caused enormous damage to and
great many of the marbles by cleaning
them with wire brush when that was back
in a mighty Legion when I was an altar
team I believe there is a mixture of
natural and artificial light the Stygian
groove of London doesn't prevent people
from seeing the marbles and they
wouldn't be particularly enhanced by but
every of every every place in which they
are exhibited and they're exhibited in
various places it uses a mixture of
natural and artificial life not going to
make a great deal different Andrew
George photo on that question that was
raised which is the slippery slope I
know you Steve when you said you don't
like that but the fact of the matter is
why the Parthenon sculptures and not
other artifacts well I mean I just don't
follow this kind of floodgate slippery
slope argument at all every case has its
own very unique and different merit and
each one has to be taken on its merits
and and if you don't take each case on
its merit then and you believe that
you're simply establishing a precedent
which which will result in this slippery
slope you end up with us with this
perverse situation where we seem to be
saying that we cannot give you justice
because we may have to give justice to
someone else in in the future I mean I
mean this is this is clear clearly
clearly not sensible but it is true or
false that everybody thinks their own
cultural artifacts are of supreme
importance and that's why there is no
slippery say why one does have to take
account of the argument about precedent
because it's legal precedent that's the
danger we have international conventions
who avenges 954 1917 1983 and 2003
which govern the and regulate the
exchange of cultural artifacts around
the world and we need to adhere to those
conventions because if we breach them if
we were to reach them by submitting to
the demand for the return of the
parthenon marbles or any other similar
artifact there are many many different
objects reachable are actually far happy
to make our perform a better case to
their restitution including you know the
Bennion bronzes the Ashanti treasure the
looting of the the syringa patan a whole
lot of the comics I designed some of
them mason makings and artifacts in the
last time would have been relocated if
the demons were to take a precedent of
the sort deal involve those
international agreements why make an
exception of the Parthenon sculptures I
mean there are so many things that's the
bust of Nefertiti in in Germany
absolutely there are all kinds of works
at the British Museum alone an incident
I also adore the British Museum but when
I look at the these these bits he's
shaved off sawing off bits of this
massive temple that was erected to
celebrate the triumph of Athens and I
was to start off the beginning of the
Athenian Empire and I'm not embarrassed
to be a Eurocentric about that because
I'm European I'm fascinated by the
building bronzes I'm fascinated by by
civilizing that they should be
repatriated no I it's just that is just
another way of saying the slippery slope
it seems to me there is such a clearly
unique case to be made there was an
individual who went specifically and
fraudulently took away from a building
pieces vital pieces of a narrative
frieze and the meta pays that described
that city's existence at the time in
that country was under occupation that
20 years later it was a country again
and Athens was its new capital and we
should have said where we've saved them
for you now it's time we can give them
back to you it doesn't mean we have to
give back the rosetta stone to whom
would we give it back we don't know to
whom it belongs
but we do know to
the Pathan belongs it belongs to the
people of Athens and the people of
Greece okay yep lady here I have a real
issue with this denial of occupation of
Greece I'm part Turkish and I can safely
say Greece was occupied it's as simple
as that regardless of municipalities the
Ottoman Empire - the occupation it was
just the parallel with Nazi Germany I'm
sorry - England you can compare to
England occupy in France or Rome
occupying ancient the British Isles
whatever it was still an occupied nation
and it's very dubious how those marbles
were taken away that's all I have to say
thank you no comments or Shh
lovely in Greece I mean during
international is oh I am for
internationalism but I think it would be
polite to ask for the other party with
pieces of its civilization it wants to
ser and reply to the why question why
the marbles I think it's the obvious for
me the integrity of it I mean it's a one
piece of art it's supposed to be
together
and I think that's the manor but can we
go back to you are you absolutely
certain in terms of the Egyptian
artifacts in the National Archaeological
Museum in Athens that you would you are
absolutely certain about the elements of
their restitution about Egypt wanting
them back what does this do to a new
European a Mediterranean culture when
everyone wants everything back just
missing so you give them back yes an
actually gave tract and nobody doesn't
demand you hold what the wonder of your
the wonder of European civilisation is
this exchange of art and artifacts if we
look at the history of King Charles a
second if we look at the history of King
Philip the second you have extraordinary
royal collections you have extraordinary
national collections which are shared
out over centuries across Europe why do
we want to particularly at this time of
crisis and stress all retreat back into
our own narrow cultural identity I'm not
arguing for anything like that I'm just
saying I don't know how I don't know if
you've seen the figures I mean you have
a dorsal and that the chest is missing I
mean how is that something that it's
worth being it's like is it here it's
like it's like you're tearing the Mona
Lisa in half and how we come in two
different locations one's clearly absurd
one great minister said it's like a
family portrait with loved ones missing
isn't it just very quickly tell us how
big an issue is this in Greece obviously
everybody wants them back I mean is it a
very big live issue but with the
economic crisis it's on the back burner
well it is always a major issue I mean
if a Greeks learn now that the British
would be willing to discuss it who would
probably forget about the crisis and we
read about the Greeks you know
supporting the yeren 70 or 80 percent I
mean if you ask for the marbles I think
will be much more than that close to a
hundred percent and the main argument
I'm not claiming to represent Greeks
I've been living here for 11 years but I
think that the main argument is the
moral one it's a unite it's one piece of
art and it's supposed to be together
I do hope everybody does understand I
hope it's common ground on the platform
that the the the reason why the marbles
are divided and why they're so few of
the pieces are intact is that for many
centuries the Parthenon was subject to
the most outrageous pillage and
destruction the biggest of which was
when it was converted into a Christian
Church land father when it was converted
into a Muslim mosque and then when the
Venetians blew it up and then when they
the Turks but when elgyn got there he
intended only to make casts but he found
that the local population were grinding
up the statues for for lime and the
Turks are using them as target practice
I really must stop you minigolf I mean
yeah we're going to run out of time okay
who's got the microphone
hi this is not a view of scholarship
this is a layman's interpretation but it
seems to me if we Herald exchange with
you spoke about Tristram Chilean
exchange not based on pillage but based
on a classy act and goodwill is really
is born out cosmopolitan it's born out
of a sense of internationalism we would
achieve the same ends if we were to
return them and we'd still achieve
exchange but be based on good well all
right
pass the microphone
very briefly I'll be very brief Tasos
it's hopeless and another Greek in the
audience I just want to say that there
was some very admirable and and reasoned
arguments on by both Tristram and Andrew
on on either side but but for me as a
Greek it was extremely touching to see
the the passion and the heartfelt
emotional argument that that mr. Frye
gave so I just want to say thank you
from my behalf and other Greeks
this young boy here and then that's it
okay
Britain has a wonderful history of
idiocy in arrogance mr. frog mr. fry
said that we could make perfect copies
of these marbles and casts cast yet
that's it if we gave them back we could
have perfect copies of them and the
friendship of the Greeks I would far
prefer that to the originals I don't see
how that helps us at all all right well
I got to leave it there Alton thank you
very much indeed for your contributions
audience I now have the results of the
voting that's been taking place as we've
had these uh final interventions from
the floor let me remind you first of all
how you the audience voted when you came
in before the debate for the motion that
reminds you send them back the Parthenon
Marbles should be returned to Athens for
the motion 196 against was up 202 s2 and
the dope knows were a hundred and fifty
eight this is how you voted after the
debate for the motion 384 against
against the motion sorry 125 the joke
knows were only 24 so you lost 77 votes
I'm afraid and you gained the lion's
share
congratulations to the winners
commiserations to the losers thank you
to all our speakers thank you to you the
audience in Cadogan Hall and thank you
also the BBC world television audience
wherever you are wherever you're
watching from me Zainab Adamic Cadogan
Hall in central London goodbye
you